[Musique]
avec hélène frade bonjour hélène bonjour
damien ya là une d'abord ces révélations
sur le crédit suisse accusée d'avoir
hébergé secrètement près 200 milliards
d'euros dont une partie pour le compte
de clients particulièrement sulfureux
jusqu'à présent les comptes bancaires
suisses étaient un secret bien gardé
derrière des murs épais mais grâce à une
source anonyme nous sommes en mesure de
montrer comment des dictateurs et des
criminels ont caché leur argent annonce
le süddeutsche zeitung
selon le journal allemand le lanceur
d'alerté à l'origine de ces révélations
affirme que son objectif est de dénoncer
le secret bancaire suisse présentée
comme une feuille de vigne destiné à
masquer la collaboration des banques
suisses avec les fraudeurs fiscaux the
guardian le quotidien britannique parle
de clients impliqués dans des affaires
de torture de trafic de drogue de
blanchiment d'argent et d'autres crimes
graves notamment d'un trafiquant d'êtres
humains aux philippines d'un patron de
la bourse de hong kong emprisonné pour
corruption de cadres accusés d'avoir
pillé la compagnie pétrolière d'état
vénézuélienne ou encore deux politiciens
corrompus de l'ukraine à l'egypte mais
des accusations que credit suisse
rejette fermement les qualifiant d'
allégations d'insinuations mais au delà
du cas de cet établissement le monde
s'inquiète de ce que le sacro-saint
article 47 de la loi bancaire suisse est
était non seulement renforcer en 2014
pour punir plus sévèrement toute
personne transmettant des informations
confidentielles à un tiers ce qui est
passible de cinq ans d'emprisonnement
mais également que cet article et été
élargie à d'autres acteurs que les
banquiers menaçant également les
lanceurs de l'air et les journalistes
qui veut dire que le risque de
poursuites prêt à la fois sur le lanceur
d' alerte qui a divulgué ces
informations sur le süddeutsche zeitung
mais aussi sur tous les journaux avec
lesquels il a partagé ses informations
le monde note qu'à ce jour cette loi n'a
jamais été utilisée contre des
professionnels de l'information mais
qu'elle fait tout de même peser une
lourde menace en particulier pour les
journalistes suisses ce qui serait
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
aucun média suisse n'a été associé à
cette enquête depuis 2014 les
journalistes risquent une condamnation
s'ils écrivent sur des données bancaires
volées pour cette raison notre journal a
dû renoncer à enquêter sur les clients
de crédit suisse regrette la tribune de
genève où le dessin de chat donc voix
montre la suisse bâillonnant ses
journalistes pour la plus grande
satisfaction des criminels du monde
entier autre sujet à la une ce matin à
l'intensification des efforts
diplomatiques ces dernières heures pour
empêcher une guerre dans l'est de
l'ukraine à l'issue d'une course
diplomatique effréné emmanuel macron
vous l'avez dit a obtenu hier de joe
biden et vladimir poutine la tenue d'un
sommet sur l'ukraine un sommet qui ne
pourra avoir lieu que si la russie
n'envahit pas l'ukraine 1 selon l'elysée
cité par courrier international
le magazine cite également en deux
gardiennes qui note que le président
français n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour
convaincre ses homologues selon le
quotidien britannique cette lueur
diplomatique suggère que vladimir
poutine pourrait être disposé à ne pas
franchir le pas d'une invasion complète
de l'ukraine afin de permettre donc de
nouvelles discussions mais que si ce
n'est pas le cas alors il se serait
engagé dans une tromperie très
sophistiqué je cite des français compris
ou non le quotidien russe nezavissimaïa
gazeta fait l'hypothèse en tout cas de
ce que le temps des branches d'olivier
pourrait être terminée étant donné
l'aggravation de la situation à l'est de
l'ukraine une flambée de violence qui
serait à l'origine de la décision
annoncée ce matin par le 'financial
times' de la biélorussie et de la russie
de poursuivre leurs exercices militaires
conjoints supposé s'achever hier la
crise on d'ukraine largement évoqué ce
matin par les dessinateurs de presse
outre-manche et nicolas jennings pour
guardian montre emmanuel macron juché
sur olaf scholz lui même soutenu par joe
biden qui piétine brent johnson de sous
la tente de stopper avec le petit
chapeau de clown en tentant de stopper
le char de la dîmière poutine avec le
drapeau de l'otan sous l'oeil du
président ukrainien wladimir zelensky
les bras croisés le président poutine
qu'on retrouve dans le dessein de brian
à coke pour deux gardiennes toujours
premier temps que non il n'a pas
d'arrière pensée la poupée russe cas
chante à l'intérieur d'elle-même le
monstre de la guerre les dessinateurs de
presse britannique dont on ne se lasse
pas et qui reviennent aussi ce matin sur
une actualité nettement moins dramatique
quoique la reine elizabeth vous l'avez
dit testée positive au coc u19 sont
heureusement pour elle ces symptômes
seraient léger selon à buckingham palace
mais la nouvelle tombe mal pour boris
johnson puisque le premier ministre
britannique doit annoncer aujourd'hui
même sa stratégie pour vivre avec le co
vie d'un malgré les nombreuses critiques
sur cette fin peut être prématuré des
restrictions sanitaires on a vaincu le
colis d'un god forbid down dit la fiche
de downing street comme quoi la reine
cet angle barry johnson un dessin de
motoball and poor's
merci beaucoup et l'aide